hey 42 here hello
this episode is actually about not being
here
we're going to reveal the secrets that
help the most high-performing people
in the world achieve extraordinary
things by
tuning out of reality and accessing
altered states of consciousness
but first a test imagine dawn on the
edge of the savannah
a hundred thousand years ago you are a
homo sapien
awoken by the sun and prepared to fight
another day
as you leave the shelter of your cave to
fetch water you suddenly freeze
behind the nearest bush you spot an
indistinct brown mass
do you a assume it's a rock chuckle it
yourself for getting a fright
and carry on with your morning or b
assume it's a saber-toothed tiger soil
your loincloth a little
and reach for the nearest spear the
answer is b
and regardless of what you may tell
yourself you had no choice in that
decision
your brain already made that call for
you before you consciously saw that
brown shape
behind the bush this is thanks to
negativity bias a survival mechanism
that evolved to keep us alive
by assuming the worst and making it
easier for your brain to recall negative
experiences
than positive ones it's easy to
understand why this trait exists
let's say you early human saw a brown
mass
and assumed it was a saber-toothed tiger
but later discovered that it was
in fact a rock sure you would look a bit
like a fool in front of the rest of your
tribe mates and have to endure nicknames
like
leaky loins but at least you'd be alive
but if you saw a brown mass assumed it
was a rock
and five seconds later found yourself
knee-deep in a saber-toothed tiger's
jaws
that would be the last mistake you ever
made
simply put through successive
generations of natural selection
those who assumed an inherently cautious
view of the world
were more likely to survive and so the
negativity bias trait
or as i like to call it holy [ __ ]
nuggets that's mike myers in my [ __ ]
bathroom
oh no it's just a dressing gown endured
and as my dressing gown demonstrated
last night
it still plagues our brains today
modern science has confirmed negativity
biases existence
in one neurological study participants
were shown a series of positive
negative or neutral images the negative
images
triggered higher levels of electrical
activity in the brain
this may not sound like a big deal but
this directly impacts the way we see the
world and
consequently behave negative events are
much more salient
and hence some people end up in therapy
because they think their entire life is
a train wreck
when in fact 95 of it consists of
positive experiences
only they're long forgotten at the
expense of the negative
do you ever find yourself ruminating
over past events or worrying about
what's going to happen in the future
of course you do not because you're a
psycho and
should be watching this from a padded
cell although
if you are here's a small tip find the
really tall native looking bloke
and tell him to throw a sink through the
window
no your past haunts you because you're
human and your brain is pre-programmed
to find the negative in everything the
thing is
this survival mechanism is just not as
useful as it used to be
unless you owe them a lot of money
you're unlikely to spend your days
worrying about tigers
instead you'll be obsessing over the
possibility of
losing your relationships your job or
your money
that might seem sensible it may even
motivate you to work harder and be less
of a dick to people
but it's not going to bring you
happiness or peace of mind
because even when you think your mind is
at rest
it isn't instead you've got
a non-stop house party going on between
your
ears thoughts and feelings continually
dancing
to lousy hip-hop and playing beer-pong
that's right your brain gets invited to
more exciting parties than you do
neuroscientists have found the source of
this is something they like to call
default mode network this is a
large-scale brain network primarily
composed of the medial frontal cortex
posterior cingulate cortex and the
angular gyrus
which is sadly not as naughty as it
sounds
studies have shown that even when test
subjects are apparently
calm and at rest the default mode
network
remains highly active engaged in
constant and random
mental chatter some people call this
monkey mind
which is probably quite offensive to
monkeys but at least a good description
of how
nuts this inner nattering is
unfortunately due to negativity bias
most of this internal chatter is quite
unpleasant
imagine an episode of real housewives
but instead of slagging off each of his
husbands and tit
jobs it's all directed at you it's
exhausting
and it makes you feel crap so what do
you do
well here's a quote after a heavy week
at work
nothing helps me unwind like a long
glass of water
and some quality time dwelling on my
mistakes
do you know who said that nobody ever
when humans feel overburdened by the
weight of daily life and the voice in
their heads
they don't look for a way to check in
they look for a way to
check out to help explain what i mean
here's another quote
a real one this time from george bernard
shaw
alcohol is the anesthesia by which we
endure
the operation of life for george
it was alcohol maybe for you it's
electronic dance music
instagram elicits drugs prescription
drugs
porn or yoga everyone has some way of
getting out of their own head
and accessing an altered state
of course some of these methods are
healthier than others
i'm obviously not advocating drug use
here but the objective
is always the same tune out of ordinary
consciousness
in their book stealing fire authors
steve kotler
and jamie wheel calculate the altered
state's economy which is made up of
many activities that people use to snap
out of reality
they estimate it to be worth more than
four
trillion dollars a year that's big
business
but it's also nothing new cultures all
around the world have been experimenting
with altered states
for a long time possibly as far back as
000 years ago most of these activities
were part of
sacred rites and often involved
hallucinogenic substances
whilst you may enjoy a couple of beers
on a friday night
the mayans took drinking to such an
advanced level that they stopped
drinking altogether
instead they took alcohol as an enema
usually mixed with other psychoactive
substances
until they were totally pissed and as
blissed out as it is possible to be so
in a megalomanic sacrificial central
american ancient civilization
don't fancy chugging cocaine and green
tea up your ass
well in greece the lucy in mysteries
saw altered states elevated to a cult
level
eventually influencing the evolution of
western philosophy
for nearly 2 000 years the mysteries
promoted clandestine rituals
that incorporated ecstatic dancing
fasting and the consumption of a drink
called kikium
all of which were designed to shift the
initiate state of mind
kikio the barley based elixir that was
consumed at the climax of the process
had a profound effect on those who
consumed it probably it seems because
they were tripping off their damn faces
modern anthropologists think that kikion
was made from barley that contained
ergot a parasitic fungus that commonly
infects grains
ergot releases ergometrine
and delacergic acid amide a chemical
precursor
to lsd other researchers believe that
the kikion recipe
may rather have included magic mushrooms
which grew naturally in the area around
ellucis
regardless of ingredients this potion
was potent enough to require
hardcore protection revealing its
secrets or drinking kiki on
outside the ellucian mysteries was
punishable by death
it also stimulated the thinking of
philosophical heavyweights like
socrates plato and pythagoras that's
right the triangle guy
it turns out you were right all along
the guy who came up with those
theorems really was on something
whether you're talking about kickion in
greece peyote cactus in central and
north america
ayahuasca in south america or iboga in
central africa
altered state traditions have been
around for thousands of years
typically intertwined with spirituality
and culture
the pursuit of altered states is so
fundamental
that it transcends humanity dolphins
have been documented getting stoned on
pufferfish
african elephants get drunk on
fermenting marula fruit
cats can't resist catnip dogs lick toads
to get high
bees get stoned on orchid nectar this
behavior is so
typical that ucla psychopharmacologist
which i swear just sounds like an excuse
to combine two professions into one
ronald segal once wrote the pursuit of
intoxication with drugs
is a primary motivational force in the
behavior of organisms
what the desire to get high is a
significant
driver of human behavior i thought it
was money or
sex or something or sex with your money
that's a pretty radical suggestion
anyway or is it
i know you might be saying oh i tried it
once but i never inhaled or
no thanks 42 i wouldn't touch the stuff
but don't you already have some vice
that you use in your life to
change your mood or mental state booze
cigarettes sugar coffee
or maybe you prefer to use a healthier
method like meditation
running or drinking yak milk but what
you do
is not as important as why most people
are trying to change their state of mind
because they're chasing pleasure
or avoiding pain but an increasing
number of people
are using altered states to go beyond
feeling better to performing better
the best known example of this is the
flow state
mahai chiksen mahayu a psychologist who
literally wrote the book on the subject
describes flow as a state in which
people are so involved
in an activity that nothing else seems
to matter
your concentration is so intensely
focused on the task at hand
that there's nothing left over for the
monkey mind to scratch and nibble at as
a result
your problems recede entirely
you enter the zone a state of tremendous
productivity
and creativity that feels timeless
selfless and effortless you can probably
recall the time that you've tasted this
whether it was work
a hobby creating something or playing a
sport
most people have had at least one
experience of being so immersed in
something
that hours went by without notice
when you fought back on it it seemed
like the head state you are in was
not your usual pattern of renumeration
regret reasoning and other words
starting with r if you can recall such a
time
you know that this state feels really
really good
that's one of the reasons that
scientists have been studying flow
and trying to understand how to trigger
it
other than feeling like the physical
manifestation of batman mixed with jesus
that's jesus another reason you'll want
to achieve flow
is that it's an optimal state for
performance
and productivity you don't enter flow
when drifting around on a lilo or
scanning pictures of self-loathing
morons on instagram
how about watching thought-provoking
youtube videos presented by an
antiquated englishman
i hear you asked i think well i'd love
to say
yes but what you're doing right now will
only get you halfway to entering the
fabled flow state
i am here to challenge your
understanding of the world with new
ideas and information
but chick central high use research
shows
that achieving flow relies on personal
challenge and skill the task you're
doing
needs to challenge you but you also need
to have
just enough skill to do it too much
difficulty without sufficient ability
causes anxiety too much skill without
enough of a challenge
leads to boredom no challenge and no
required skill
is called apathy if you're in that state
be sure to check yourself regularly for
a pulse and
excess drool flow is an
active state which is why most of the
studies done on the phenomenon
have focused on athletes and extreme
sports professionals
these test subjects report having hugely
amplified access to
pattern recognition future prediction
and information processing capabilities
when in the zone or flow you can make
better decisions
faster faster even than conscious
thought
bizarrely that's because during flow the
part of your brain
usually in charge of decision making
your prefrontal cortex
is temporarily bypassed why
because it slows you down and being in
flow state is all about
reacting and thinking at superhuman
speed
during flow states your brain is filled
with a cocktail of neurochemicals that
makes you feel alert and ecstatic
norepinephrine
heightens your concentration dopamine
improves your cognitive alertness
endorphins activate the opioid receptor
which
along with anandamide brings on the
feeling of bliss
serotonin lifts your mood finally
a good shot of oxytocin the love hormone
leaves you with a sort of post-orgasmic
glow
that follows most flow episodes if by
now you think the flow state has a lot
in common with the other
non-ordinary states i mentioned earlier
such as the
mayan whiskey up your arse state as i
like to call it
you're not wrong feelings of bliss
expanded consciousness
higher creativity connection with
something greater
it turns out that these are universal
qualities of heightened altered states
regardless of whether you enter them
through psychedelics
or big wave surfing what i'm essentially
saying is you don't need drugs to get
high mahael chiksen mahayu
has even compared the flow state to
tripping
in one interview calling flo a kind of
toned down ecstasy but research into
phloem has revealed that altered states
in general
have more potential than weekend
entertainment or conversations with yoda
and these states can be hacked firstly
you have to get your mind right research
by faculty at the university of
portsmouth
found that instructing a group of rock
climbers in positive psychology tools
like
goal setting self-talk and mindfulness
increased the intensity of their flow
states
whilst also elevating personal
performance try meditation
positive mindset development cognitive
behavioral therapy
exercise and good sleep and after that
you could channel pink floyd and
tap into your brain waves there are five
main brain wave frequencies
gamma beta alpha theta and delta
beta is where you spend most of your
time whilst focused and alert
alpha is where you're at when you're
relaxed and open-minded
like when you're daydreaming fata is
associated with more profound states of
mind like meditation
the flow state happens at the bridge
between alpha
and theta when the mind is moving from
the conscious
into the subconscious similarly
scientists at imperial college london's
center for psychedelic research yes
that's a thing found people on the south
american hallucinogenic plant
ayahuasca had brain patterns resembling
those of people
who are awake in their dreams finally
more and more people use substances to
nudge them in the right direction
no i'm not proposing you drop free tubs
of acid with your cornflakes on a monday
morning
i'm not even suggesting you microdose
yourself with
tiny daily amounts of psychedelics as
has become
weirdly popular in silicon valley tech
and other high pressure
high creativity industries it seems that
just focusing
on good vitamins and nutrients all made
from totally legal ingredients of course
can support the optimal brain
functioning needed
to access these high performing states
of course the fact that you've watched
this whole video confirms
that you're already a peak stage
champion go
treat yourself to a biscuit and thanks
for watching
what's that i hear you say you want to
experience my new book
stick a flag in it but you can't be
asked to read
i hear you that's why you can now get
the audio book release of sticker flag
in it
over on audible you'll find the link in
the description
below thank you